served as an infantry captain in the
army national guard and as a veteran of
the war in afghanistan he's also co-host
of fox and friends weekend pete thank
you for being here that it's a really
stunning interview just listening to
trey talking to a member of the haqqani
network who says that the united states
is not upholding its side of the bargain
so this is where we are with this peep
this is where we are because we made a
deal with the devil and make no mistake
about it the haqqani network is the
devil the economy network is a wing of
al qaeda
this uh the the man who uh trey yingst
interviewed is the brother of sriracha
connie siraj akani is the interior
ministry with a million dollar 10
million bounty on his head the current
inside the cabinet of the taliban where
he controls the interior ministry which
is the police and the intelligence
forces he is in charge of combating
terrorism think about how rich that is
so someone who's in bed with al-qaeda is
in charge of combating terrorism there's
one thing i know about jihadists they
believe they can lie at will to the
infidels to the west to advance their
view and that's exactly what you're
seeing right now with this charm
offensive with this pr offensive that
the taliban hakadi and al-qaeda together
are putting on they're trying to pretend
like this state run by the taliban will
be like just any other nation state and
that ultimately we can trust them other
countries should bring in their
embassies and and it all will be well
when what we all know is those lies are
all justified by jihadists because it
advances their cause against the west
and americans they seek to expel every
single one kill as many as they can if
they can they made a bargain with a weak
bide administration that they believe
gave them everything they wanted and
you're covering that uh ceremony of one
of the 13 that was killed uh that that
death is a result of a deal with the
devil that was ultimately never in our
control that had us talking tale and
leaving afghanistan and now and trey
yings is doing great work but now we're
doing interviews with haqqani who's
trying to justify that there's some sort
of a legitimate government when all they
are is a mega terror state that would
love to hit us again if they could
it's astonishing
and he says we're not living up to our
side of the agreement we've got 64
billion i think in aid that is
designated to go uh to help people in
afghanistan we know from past history uh
whose pockets a lot of that will end up
in whoever's in charge it used to be the
afghan government now it's going to most
likely be the taliban um
thanks to trey yingst who is you know
putting himself in the thick of it to
get us information from the ground in
afghanistan and pete said thank you very
much it's always good to have you with
us thank you martha